Anna:
Hey. OK, so hello everyone. Thanks for joining.
This is a technical design review focused on ID indexed component
and improvements we are planning to roll out in this quarter.
Anna:
This is one of our key cost driven initiatives for this quarter.
This session is primarily for engineers.
Please ask questions during the Q&A.
Anna:
Piotr Patyra will start from ID index introduction and optimisation
opportunity, followed by current implementation and proposed solution.
Piotr:
First a brief introduction into what the ID index is.
It is an internal implementation detail of the Core DB service.
Piotr:
We store the map as a sequence of changes — deltas.
Snapshots store the state of the map at a given version
so we don’t have to apply all deltas every time.
Piotr:
The map is divided into datasets.
Geometric queries hit datasets based on area,
while ID-based queries require the ID index.
Piotr:
The ID index maps feature IDs to datasets
so we know which host to query.
Piotr:
There are around 400 datasets spread across 7 database hosts.
The ID index lives next to datasets in PostgreSQL.
Piotr:
The ID index competes with dataset queries for RAM and cache.
IDs are queried randomly, making caching inefficient.
Piotr:
Around 30–40% of RAM on snapshot hosts
is consumed by the ID index.
Piotr:
The idea was to build a dedicated service
optimised specifically for this workload.
Piotr:
We split the structure into:
ID → code, and code → dataset combinations.
This reduces size substantially.
Piotr:
The file is sorted by ID and queried via binary search.
We page the file and search within pages.
Piotr:
We reduced the index size from about 2TB in Postgres
to about 330GB using this approach.
Piotr:
We forked production traffic
to compare Postgres vs the new service.
Piotr:
Latency was comparable, sometimes better.
The service ran on roughly half the resources.
Piotr:
The service is implemented in Go
for performance and controlled memory usage.
Andrew:
Were there any major risks discovered in the POC?
Piotr:
Mostly around memory usage early on.
Otherwise, no structural risks identified so far.
Michal:
Can you explain the technology choice?
Piotr:
We chose Go for low-level performance
and minimal dynamic allocation.
Stefan:
Are all IDs now in the ID index?
Piotr:
Yes. We no longer encode dataset shortcuts into IDs.
Anna:
We are running out of time.
Please follow up with Piotr for further questions.
Thanks everyone for joining.